hello everyone and welcome to a game
that was played three days ago I believe
it was played in a bleed banter session
on chest 24 between magnus carlsen and
this gentleman here a random guy off the
streets of Oslo as the chest 24 tweeted
but here's a still image from the game
there we have it maxi Boggs vs. me
upstairs and these are the two gentlemen
if you know who the person on the right
is feel free to share in the comment
section as I wasn't able to find out but
yeah that being said let's check out the
game and I also wanted to say for those
of you who don't know what hand and
brain is hand and brain chess is when
the gentleman to the right of course and
he's and names a piece for example a
pawn and then Carson has to make him
with the pawn and then if he wants to
move the knight he says night and then
Carson has to decide which move with the
night goes so let's check it out they
opened with the white pieces so key for
I played c6 the caro-kann which is
already peculiar as I never play Cora
Khan but I'm gonna return to that with
b3 I play d5 Knight to f3 and the Knight
to d7 the prayer variation of the
caro-kann Knights the c3 attacking my
point here and already I give up on here
by playing g6 it's not that I wanted to
sacrifice a pawn for rapid development I
just I just didn't register that it was
actually hanging but okay they captured
ecaps force on d5 I played Bishop to g7
I developed a piece they played captures
I played captures and I'm already down
upon a but okay I mean it's only a pawn
Bishop to e2 90 G to f6 I prepare
castling with Bishop to e3 and I Castle
kingside today also Castle kingside and
I played a5 grabbing more space in the
center I want to play nice to h5 to f4
and I want to get my knight over to a
four this would free my dark square
bishop and also maybe maybe even force
them to give up one of their bishops
with h3 taking away the g4 square from
my pieces and I continue with my plan
Knight to h5 now the bishop is nicely
freed maybe I can play f5 at some point
I want to get the night
to f4 like we said but of course they
also get a movement so d4 and it's a
very nice move you wanna get rid of your
d3 pawn you wanna free or light square
Bishop and here I should just continue
with my plan Knight to f4 and then it's
a it's a you know for a blitz game it
could be a playable position if
something like this happens for example
I could capture the light square Bishop
would check let's say Knight captures
here and the game continues but here I
play the another pawn sacrifice which is
not upon sacrifice and I don't really
have a good explanation of why played
this I played efore now it's a really a
strange move as it does absolutely
nothing it just gives up a pawn
so even capturing here was better than
then playing something like this but
okay I will return to this
they played of course knife captures on
e4 it's a free pawn and here I already
was very sad I was down two pawns and I
didn't really have anything to show for
it so I just continued f5 brush up the
c4 check which of course makes sense you
want to go Knight g5 to f7 I play King
to h8 and now Knight eat the g5 the idea
is 92 f7 would check they won of course
win the rook here I played f4 hoping for
a knight to f7 but of course they will
not play that knife to e6 was also
playable but first they decided to
retreat with the Bishop Bishop to d2 and
now I played Queen to f6 simply guarding
the f7 square twice and here's where the
party is getting started of course I
knew what was coming here Bishop to c3
you of course want your Bishop on this
very nice diagonal and there's not much
to do about it
there's no way to close it I played
Knights to be six hoping to get my
knight over to d5
but of course they decided not not to
give me this opportunity
d if I was played opening up the bishops
attack here and now there aren't really
aren't all that many good squares for my
queen III even I even thought about
giving up my queen for the bishop pair
here but there's really no point as
after characters captures and this it's
not just the bishop pair
but I'm also down three points due to
the two points I just lost in the
opening so I played Queen to e7 but here
they just continued very very strong d6
now attacking the Queen once again I
push the Queen back Queen to e8
constantly trying to keep an eye on the
f7 square but it's it's it's not
possible
rook e1 attacking the Queen even more
Queen to d8
and now Knight to e5 and here 92 f7 is
coming there's no way to stop that and
this is basically game over if I go
Queen e8 for example to avoid it I still
get Knight e to f7 opening up a
discovery to the Queen
the knight isn't nicely protected and
here I either just move the King and go
into some windmill action but the queen
is lost
either way or or even if I play Queen to
f6 doesn't really matter still night e
to f7 check now opens up the bishops
attack towards the Queen and also either
I go into some nice windmill action or
are just give up the Queen and it's game
over so here I decided to be a gentleman
and I decided to go down with Queen
captures and g5 and this allows pretty
much the same idea but it goes into mate
so of course you will see it I don't
even have to show it to you but nice to
have seven check which loses the Queen
as if I capture it's checkmate I decided
to go for the for the easier line I
played rook captures on f7 and they
played rook to e8 check Luke to f8 and
now of course rook captures on f8 and
this is now mate as the bishop is the
bishop is pinned you cannot recapture so
that's it
23 moves and I just wanted to I just
wanted to shed some light on why I
played the way I did the reason is I I
saw the Blitz Ventura session was
starting and I challenged like everyone
else I didn't really think this is like
the fourth time I tried to get a game in
and at some point my sister came came
for coffee and we were having coffee but
I wasn't sitting at my computer I just
had the volume on so I can hear if the
game actually starts and the game
actually started I rent
computer and I wanted to make a move as
soon as possible
so they don't abort the game as if I
wasn't at the computer that's why I
played c6 that's why I played the
caro-kann even though I never played the
car O'Connor which was I played it and I
was like what did I just play and this
all I mean yeah and oh one other thing I
didn't know I was playing against the
Magnus and his friend in a hand and
brain session I thought it was Magnus
alone because when I left the computer
Magnus was still playing by himself so
here I was just I played c6 what what am
i doing and then this just all came very
quickly Knight f3 Knight d7 and here
like I said Knight c3 g7 g6 just giving
up a pawn and you know it all it all
went downhill from there then I on my
second monitor I managed to set up the
stream so I can also watch the stream
while I play and then I realized I was
actually playing against the hand and
brain but it was just too late by that
time I tried try to make some moves but
after that efore move which I simply
can't explain even now trying to find
some logic behind it I fail to find the
logic behind it but I don't know it just
it just happened so it's it's not the
greatest of games but as a lot of you
wanted to see it I think a lot of you
thought actually it was a game against
Magnus himself so that's why I wanted to
see it but here it is just so you know
it's a game against Magnus and his body
here in a hand and brain session and
yeah that's that's pretty much it so
like I said I tried to do something get
back into the game covered f7 square but
it was even again even even you know it
wasn't actually Magnus who decided which
piece moves when it was his friend but
the position was so bad that there was
just no going back
and I don't know I thought about first I
thought about showing it but then I had
this eye situation and I didn't record
any videos for two days and then as you
guys were requesting it for so much I
decided to show it as it is it is quite
a you know a funny game that
to put it lightly and it's not that it's
not that I mind losing anyone who knows
me will tell you the same thing I've
never had a problem with with losing or
even making you know a fool of myself as
it's all it's only good promotion of
chess so I of course don't mind and even
if I didn't blunder any any pawns you
know I it's hard to say that the result
would be different than then it was here
but yeah I'll still keep on challenging
him maybe maybe I will get another game
and then hopefully I will not to get so
excited and start the blundering pawns
all over the place but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I can tell
you I I did not enjoy it and yeah for
those of you who missed a couple Blanca
video the final game of the capablanca
saga the shades are not for you know for
fashion purposes that I actually have an
eye condition on my right eye
I've minted a doctor today and I
received an ointment for it but she said
it will take a few days before it heals
and up until then I will have to record
using sunglasses not distract you from
all the wonderful chess not wonderful
chest like this here but other wonderful
chests for them for example at tomorrow
the World Cup is starting so we're gonna
enjoy that but yeah like I said you
requested it so there it is I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I would like to
thank dog McNab law office John Butler
Donna
Donald Pettingill Amarjit Saudi and Jeff
Sealy for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon not
continuing the capablanca saga we're
done with that I still have to do the
conclusion video but I will do that
after my eye heals I don't feel like
doing it which shades it's a you know
too too important of a video
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and as of
tomorrow we are starting off the World
Cup so thank you I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest really